hey you yeah you
you smell that that
sweet tantalizing odor of zero ping and
horizontally arrayed fist bumps that
dear viewer is the smell of csgo
on land counter-strike ladies and
gentlemen
is back this past weekend we watched
navi 30g2 in the grand finals of iem
clone which for those who may have
forgotten is the first land we've had
in 16 months eerily enough
it was the exact same result as we saw
at the last land in
february of 2020 which
kind of begs the question was the
so-called
online era really just an asterisk
[Music]
all right so you know what i'm going to
say why even make me say it
like the video subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications
all right karambits ain't cheap and your
boys got to pay the bills somehow
okay so for the woefully uninitiated
this past weekend we saw the climactic
close
of iem cologne the so-called cathedral
of counter-strike
and the first land event that cs go has
had in
like literally a year and a half
needless to say
the community was beyond excited for
this event
for what felt like an eon we'd been
watching the same regional rivals square
off against each other
over and over again and now finally
we got a chance to see who the actual
best team in the world was
and boy did we get an answer a little
chance oh the double
double brutal look at the hell they're
gone it's over
it's all over a 1v5 demanded of almanac
the impossible
it's not happening navi that's brilliant
stuff
16 months after their decisive victory
at iem katowice
the last land before kovid navi
coasted their way to yet another esl
title
in cologne the crazy thing is that in
spite of how much counter-strike has
changed in that time the result was
exactly the same navi literally 3-0 to
the exact same team
albeit a different roster in a sweep so
clean
it made sentinels running reykjavik look
like a nail-biter
see i'm hip with the kitties i watch
valorant sometimes
what this means of course is well it
isn't exactly clear what it means
is simple still the greatest
counter-strike player in the world
yes undoubtedly literally even less of a
conversation than before
and yeah and second hi haters i'm here
again
it's easy cameras lights
everything yeah just uh just know your
place haters
i'm just kidding just price this [ __ ] to
me next time as well
[Laughter]
taking into account his 1.51 rating
the mvp medal that pretty much had his
name on it from day one
and the four aces he racked up the most
anyone has ever secured at a big event
ever this was arguably the greatest
individual performance
of any player in cs go history and that
wasn't lost on him both posted up
fires off a warning shot and simple as
well does one better and they're just
walking in
oh my goodness one more for the ace alex
record breaking ace
simple to break the record no one has
found four aces and a tournament
like this and here it comes a record
breaker from simply takes all five
as for navi as a whole are they still
the greatest roster in the world
despite struggling at times over the
course of the online era
i mean yeah it it would appear as if
they are
in addition to regaining their spot as
hltv's world number one
they clap pretty much everyone in sight
it does feel
as if as soon as it returned to lane
counter-strike picked up
right where it left off which feels kind
of crazy
look i don't buy into this whole
narrative that the online era somehow
didn't matter
like it was just a blip and the results
don't count
i believe that burgeoning budding
rosters like heroic
vertis pro and gambit did great things
over the past year and a half
and will continue to do great things the
issue
is that given what happened this past
weekend
there's no denying that these up and
comers didn't
quite clap as hard as we thought they
would when all was said and done
the final four came down to a couple of
classic
land-hardened bruisers not the onliners
aside from getting to see simple smurf
on one of his game's
biggest stages we got to see nico look
like a top three player again
astralis dish out some disgusting
dumpsters
without device and olaf
roll back the years one one dig at a
time
pre-aiming and toes are starting off
does respond
all right a 2v3 we can work with that
he's very loud about this i'm not sure
about this at all and what
is that from all of my stuff look at the
wrist yo
like tell me this beautiful swedish
bastard
isn't the goat go on please tell me
like this guy's retired two if not three
times
he just casually rolls into cologne
claps kids left and right
and just nabs himself a top four finish
like what a [ __ ] gangster are you mad
because i'm not anyway this is all to
say that i have no idea who's going to
win the major
or whether navi is indeed going to go on
to win the grand slam
i do think that all of these onliners
are still
immensely strong it was one event
for some of them it was their first
don't be so quick to discount them
oh and to top it all off there was one
other nifty little detail that made
cologne
a tournament to remember twas blessed
with a shroudy rowdy co-stream i still
can't believe they let me do this
it was so out of the blue just like hey
esl
can i uh co-cast this can i stream it on
my stream
after a week of silence they're like
yeah sure it was
only fitting that this should happen at
cologne of course
since it was in the semi-finals of esl
one cologne 2017
that shroud produced one of the most
goosebump-inducing highlights of his
career
almost looked like skadoodle had
actually come out on top there
what a flick coming in trout getting one
of the headshots he's tapping away
shroud
could he do it again he's up to 11 kills
and looking for number 12
are you kidding me shroud four kills
can anyone take this man down now this
was a big move for cs go
not only is shroudy rowdy coming back to
counter-strike always a
big fat you love to see it but it could
spell
big things for the future of esl
co-streams
since they've infamously been very
obstinate about letting streamers watch
their events
live on twitch of course if there's one
streamer you just
can't say no to it's shroud the man's
co-streams have done
wonders for valorent outperforming the
mainstream on virtually every occasion
in fact it's pretty much gotten to the
point where it's understood that for
english speakers
shroud stream is the mainstream needless
to say esl granting streaming rights to
the rowdy one
was a very intelligent move the hope is
that going forward
it'll allow other smaller streamers into
the mix like
tarik or that weird bearded boomer who
talks about
dicks all the time hey put your dicks
away
chat fix away zip em up now whether they
actually will
or everyone will just continue to hop
into shroudy's watch party
or if he even does another watch party i
have no idea
what i do know is that both in terms of
morale
and viewership cologne was a super sick
event
and as i'm sure we can all agree exactly
what cs go needed
shroud stream peaked at about 94 000
viewers whereas the official streams
peaked at about 840 000 which was more
than the last cs go major in berlin
you see contrary to popular belief there
were actually a lot of ways in which
quarantine was great for counter-strike
skin
prices for instance went to the [ __ ]
moon
what's more the player base hit an
all-time high
and actually managed to maintain it that
said
there were also a lot of ways in which
it suffered or at the very least
stagnated for as much as we as a
community gained this past year
there was also a lot that we lost
players casters
community figures whether we'll ever get
them back
what i do know is that cologne was the
breadth of fresh air that counter-strike
needed
an ever-important reminder that while
there is some sense in which cs go is
undeniably back there's an even more
important sense
in which it never really left what was
i'm most impressed with oh
simple dude this guy's a [ __ ] animal
it's so crazy like this guy is just you
can watch him do anything man he's just
just like this
he's just no gun he can't use there's no
position he can't play there's no
situation that he can like he's just he
has it all man he's a complete player
he's the greatest player he's nuts like
big fan boy big fan simple big fan dude
big fan huge fan the day simple follows
me on twitter that's my raid boss
that's the last one that's the final
boss once the day that simple follows me
on twitter i retire
that's it